[Musique]
je voyais bien merci
c'est quoi ouvre
du papier cadeau cfoot à l'est pas moi
je regarde c'est pour toi c'est eric
merci c'est quoi la devine ce que j'aime
par apple ce n'est certes non
c'est une salopette non c'est un plaid
non une sortie de bain non un édredon
non on est de redon bouyer non david
douillet non c'est un crime et non ça va
tout non c'est un canapé non c'est une
loutre non ça coûte ça non c'est un
rideau non pas c'est une planche non à
ces petites planches n'ont rien aux
coulées les noms une table non non 1 le
duplicata de mon acte de naissance
pliant doute non une autre table non du
beurre non de la poudre non un pli non
le t2 prospectus narrant la station
spatiale internationale
non un canyon ouais c'est vrai nom a à
une huître non jambon tenons un
gouvernement une attitude non non une
enclave non une fed maintenant une
grenouille non la photo de 14 ans
d'honneur disparue mystérieusement dans
un massif quelconque une ambrée rythme
antifi nom du saint venant du sable font
dans la sphère de rue jean moulin le
loup un diamètre non types d'huile dans
un pot ninja marne brûlures au second
degré premiers noms d'ornementation une
bougie de moby lines en système une
émission de télévision et à quel coût
[Applaudissements]
oui
bienvenue dans les commentaires audio je
suis vincent tyrrell jeu sur présence
d'adrien meyniel bonjour et de donald
duck barras